من هذه النافذه المطله على الحي كان هذا
الشاب يتطلع ببصره كل يوم حي باتت جدران
منازله واسقفها مساواه بالارض بعد الزلزال
الاخير الذي ضرب حي الملاح بمراكش في هذه
الازقه كانت الحياه تدب قبل ايام الا ان
الزلزال غير ملامح سكانه ورسم على وجوههم
حسره والما ودموعا يسيرون وهم يحملون ما
امكنهم حمله نحو المجهول
[موسيقى]
ما في الحي والتقينا بعد ساكنيه ممن ليس
في وسعهم الخروج او ليس لديهم وجهه يلجاون
اليها قص علينا ما عييشوه خلال الليله
المرعبه حين ضرب الزلزال حيهم في الثامن
من الشهر الجاري الرعده
وقال هو توقع هذاك تحضره
اسس الحي خلال حقبه محاكم التفتيش عام
1557 التي ارغم خلالها المسلمون واليهود
على الرحيل من اسبانيا سكن اليهود الحي
سنوات لكن تراجع عدد سكانه مع هجرتهم من
المغرب عام
1948 ثم تغير اسم الحي عام
1983 الى حي السلام وعاد الى اسمه القديم
الملاح في 2017
عندما كنا نجول في الحي لاحظنا ان معظم
سكانه من الاسر رقيقه الحال او الفقيره
التي كانت اطلقت مناشدات ونداءات استغاثه
عده مرات لترميم منازلها التي كانت ايله
للسقوط الا ان الزلزال كان اسرع من اي
استجابه
[موسيقى]
حل الظلام وما زلنا في الحي لكن على بعد
مئات الامتار كانت عشرات الاسر ممن تهدمت
منازلها ما تزال تفترش الارض في الساحات
العامه وبعضها الاخر هائمون بانتظار خبر
عن قريب او صديق في عداد المفقودين